.
>> TO GAYLE WITH CLAUS.
HEY, CLAUS.
WELCOME BACK TO "CBS THIS
MORNING."
AT LEAST 25 STATES ARE LIFTING
MASK MANDATES TO MATCH THE CDC'S
NEW GUIDANCE FOR FULLY
VACCINATED AMERICANS BUT THE
VACCINES MAY NOT PROTECT TEAM
TAKING IMMUNOSUPPRESSANT DRUGS.
10 MILLION PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY
HAVE COMPROMISED IMMUNE SYSTEMS.
THEY INCLUDE ORGAN TRANSLATE,
PATIENTS WITH LUPUS, RHEUMATOID
ARTHRITIS AND CROHN'S DISEASE.
DR. JON LaPOOK SHOWS HOW IM
IMMUNODRUGS CAN MAKE THE
VACCINES LESS EFFECTIVE.
>> Reporter: WHEN THE PANDEMIC
HIT, ROBERT MONTGOMERY WAS
CONCERNED FOR HIS PATIENTS.
>> ALL OF THESE TRANSPLANT
PATIENTS WERE ILL.
>> Reporter: AND FOR HIMSELF.
>> I WAS AWARE I COULD BECOME A
CASUALTY.
>> Reporter: A HEART RECIPIENT,
THE DOCTOR TAKES
IMMUNOSUPPRESSED MEDICINE.
HE WAS EAGER TO GET THE VACCINE.
>> BUT THAT EXCITEMENT WAS
QUICKLY DASHED.
>> Reporter: WHY?
>> I CHECKED MY ANTIBODIES TWO
WEEKS AFTER THE SECOND DOSE OF
THE PFIZER VACCINE AND I HAD
ABSOLUTELY NO DETECTABLE
ANTIBODIES.
>> Reporter: THE TEST MEASURING
THE SPECIFIC TYPE OF ANTIBODY
ELICITED BY THE VACCINE WAS
NEGATIVE.
HE SUSPECTED IT WAS BECAUSE THE
SAME MEDICINE PROTECTING ORGAN
REJECTION WAS BLOCKING THE
IMMUNE RESPONSE.
>> SO, I'M HEADED DOWN NOW TO
THE VACCINATION CENTER.
>> Reporter: HIS DOCTORS AGREED
AND PRESCRIBED A THIRD DOSE
USING A DIFFERENT VACCINE FROM
JOHNSON & JOHNSON TRYING TO
BOOST HIS IMMUNE RESPONSE.
>> I'M VERY WORRIED THAT
TRANSPLANT PATIENTS WHO ARE NOT
AWARE OF THESE RESULTS HAVE A
FALSE SENSE OF SECURITY.
>> Reporter: AT JOHNS HOPKINS,
TRANSPLANT SURGEON DORRY SEGEV.
>> I EXPECTED IT TO BE DIFFERENT
THAN IMMUNOCOMPROMISED PEOPLE
BUT NOT THIS LOW.
>> Reporter: PEOPLE WITH NORMAL
IMMUNE SYSTEMS PRODUCE
ANTIBODIES AGAINST THE VIRUS
THAT CAUSES COVID.
BUT SEGEV'S RECENT RESEARCH
FINDING AFTER BEING FULLY
VACCINATED, ALMOST HALF PRODUCE
NO ANTIBODIES AT ALL.
AND HE RECOMMENDING
IMMUNOCOMPROMISED PATIENTS
CONSIDER HAVING THEIR ANTIBODY
LEVELS TESTED.
>> IT IS NOT UNREASONABLE TO
SEEK MORE DATA IN THE FORM OF A
QUANTITATIVE, RELIABLE ANTIBODY
TEST THAT YOU THEN DISCUSS WITH
YOUR DOCTOR.
>> Reporter: THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S
STILL NOT KNOWN HOW MUCH
PROTECTION COVID-19 VACCINES
GIVE TO PATIENTS LIKE ROSEMARY
MacMANUS.
SO, YOU GET THE SECOND HOT.
SHOT.
>> UH-HUH.
>> Reporter: AND YOU'RE FEELING
WHAT?
>> I'M EXCITED THAT WE CAN START
DOING SOME NORMAL THINGS.
>> Reporter: THE MEDICATION THAT
McMANUS TAKES FOR AUTOIMMUNE
DISEASE INCLUDING RHEUMATOID
ARTHRITIS.
>> MY DOCTOR KEEPS A CLOSE EYE
ON ME AND HE DID AN ANTIBODY
TEST.
>> Reporter: WHAT DID IT SHOW?
>> IT SHOWS I HAVE NO
ANTIBODIES.
>> Reporter: WHAT DID YOU SAY TO
YOUR HUSBAND?
>> I'M GOING TO HAVE TO GET THE
VACCINE AGAIN.
>> Reporter: McMANUS IS
CONSIDERING GETTING A THIRD SHOT
TO SYSTEM LIT AN IMMUNE
RESPONSE.
HOW MANY TIMES DAYS AFTER THAT
DAYS OFF THAT SHOT DID IT SHOW?
>> OFF THE CHARTS ANTIBODIES.
>> Reporter: WHAT WOULD YOUR
ADVICE BE FOR THOSE WITH IMMUNE
O
0 SUPPRESSANT THERAPIES?
>> HANG IN THERE.
>> Reporter: SEVERAL OF HIS
PATIENTS HAD TO BE HOSPITALIZED
AFTER CONTRACTING COVID-19.
AND DR. SEGEV TELLS ME HE GETS
ABOUT 1200 EMAILS A DAY FROM
WORRIED PATIENTS.
AND HE SAID GET A THIRD VACCINE.
>> I LIKE THE RESPONSE WHEN HE
SAID OFF THE CHARTS.
JON, GOOD TO SEE YOU IN THE
STUDIO.
WE LOVE WHEN THIS HAPPENS.
SO MANY DIFFERENT LAYERS.
HOW DOES THIS AFFECT THOSE WHO
HAVE THE COMPROMISED SYSTEMS?
>> DR. ROCHELLE WALENSKY THE
DIRECTOR OF CDC SPECIFICALLY
SAID IF YOU'RE ON CHEMOTHERAPY,
A CONDITION LIKE THAT, THAT CAN
WEAKEN THE RESPONSE TO VACCINES,
YOU GOT TO CHECK WITH YOUR
CLINICIAN BEFORE TAKING OFF THE
MASK.
>> SO, WHAT ARE THE QUESTIONS
YOU SHOULD BE ASKING YOUR
DOCTOR?
WHAT THE QUESTION IS THE BIG
QUESTION, GAYLE, MAYBE CHECK
YOUR ANTIBODY LEVEL TO THAT
SPIKE PROTEIN.
THE PROBLEM IS, HERE'S A NEW
TERM, THE CARLETTE OF
PROTECTION, I KNOW IT'S A FANCY
TERM, WHAT CORRELATES WITH WHAT
LEVEL OF PROTECTION?
WE DO NOT KNOW YET.
I SPOKE WITH DR. WALENSKY
YESTERDAY ABOUT THAT.
STAY TUNED, WE DON'T WANT THESE
PEOPLE TO HAVE A FALSE SECURITY.
NOTHING CHANGES.
THEY STILL NEED TO DOUBLE-MASK
UNTIL WE FIGURE OUT MORE EXACTLY
WHAT THE RISK IS FOR THEM.
>> THE CORRELATED PROTECTION
SEEMS CLUNKY UNTIL YOU EXPLAIN.